madam deputy speaker the housing sector  supports over half a million jobs  the carton stamp duty i announced last  summer has helped  hundreds of thousands of people buy a  home and supported the economy  at a critical time but due to the sheer  volume of transactions we're seeing  many new purchases won't complete in  time for the end of march  so i can announce today the 500 000  pound  nil rate band will not end on the 31st  of march  it will end on the 30th of june  then to smooth the transition back to  normal  the nil rate band will be 250 000 pounds  double  its standard level until the end of  september  and we will only return to the usual  level of 125  000 pounds from october the 1st  you